This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全展开的坦诚对话。但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一身铠甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这么做。听听
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的教训》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾多次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。侦探们花费了大量网络侦探的力量，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即TWA percent，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here. Before we jump into this week's episode, I have a really exciting announcement. We launched merch last week for the podcast. It was designed in collaboration with my friend Sydney, who was on the show recently, back when we did
相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们。相信我，宝贝》，在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴能邀请到你。在我们切入本周的主题之前，我有一个非常兴奋的宣布。我们在上周为播客推出了周边产品。它是与我的朋友悉尼合作设计的，她最近曾做客节目，当时我们做了
the dating in our 20s episode. She is a local Melbourne artist. We have sweatshirts and tote bags. We ship worldwide. And it's an amazing way to support the show, to show your love, to have a really cool piece of fashion, a cool item to wear out and about. So if you would like to purchase a sweatshirt, a tote bag, maybe both, whatever you're feeling, please feel free to go to the link in the podcast description or to the link on our Instagram. to get your hands on some really cool merch. This is a bit of a different episode to what we normally do. As much as this podcast is very much centered on psychology and mental health,
关于二十岁约会的节目。她是墨尔本的本地艺术家。我们有卫衣和托特包。我们提供全球配送。这是支持节目、表达喜爱、拥有时尚酷炫的单品、以及一件适合外出穿着的炫酷物件的绝佳方式。所以，如果你想购买一件卫衣、一个托特包，或者两样都买，全凭你的心意，请随时点击播客简介中的链接或我们Instagram上的链接，去抢购一些非常酷的周边吧。这期节目的主题和我们平时的风格略有不同。尽管这个播客很大程度上以心理学和心理健康为核心，
we don't often talk about specific disorders. And I get requests, you know, quite a bit to talk about conditions like personality disorders or mood disorders. But I do often shy away because I like to create content that I think everyone, one can relate to and that really brings and breaks down those universal experiences of 20 year olds, but this is a bit different. The amount of requests I get for this topic, the amount of personal experiences from friends of mine that I've heard, I just think that we can't talk about our 20s without talking about our attitude and our habits towards food and towards health and exercise. and with that comes a very necessary and I think natural discussion around eating disorders.
但我们不常谈论具体的心理障碍。我经常收到听众的要求，希望聊聊人格障碍或心境障碍等病症。但我常常避开这些，因为我喜欢创作的内容能让每个人都产生共鸣，并且真正展现和剖析二十岁人群的那些共同经历，但这期节目有点不同。我收到关于这个主题的请求数量极多，也听过太多朋友的亲身经历，我觉得我们在谈论二十岁时，就无法避开我们对食物、对健康以及对运动的态度和习惯。而随之而来的，便是一个非常必要且我认为很自然的关于进食障碍的讨论。
So today we're going to talk about it. This is obviously a really sensitive topic for some people, whether you have a lived experience or you've been impacted by the journey of a close friend or a family member. You know, this condition is so life-altering and emotional and personal. So please take a moment to reflect on whether this is the content, you need to hear today. It could be triggering. You know, I won't mind if you listen to something else. This episode will still be here when you're in a better headspace, but just something to flag. I think eating disorders don't always receive the amount of factual, reliable attention they deserve.
所以今天我们要来谈谈这个话题。对某些人来说，这显然是一个非常敏感的话题，无论你是有过亲身经历，还是曾受到身边挚友或家庭成员这段经历的影响。你知道，这种疾病太改变人生了，而且充满情感色彩又极为私密。所以请花一点时间思考一下，这是否是你今天需要听的内容。它可能会引发不适。你知道的，如果你去听别的节目，我一点也不会介意。当你处于更好的心理状态时，这期节目依然会在这里，这只是一个善意的提醒。我认为进食障碍往往没有得到它们应有的、基于事实且可靠的关注。
And when they do, it's often in a way that is really romanticized or based in misinformation or stigma. You know, we've all seen depictions of eating disorders in movies and TV shows. We've seen how disordered eating has been glamorized by social media from Tumblr to TikTok and how many misconceptions are promoted out there about eating disorders. So we're really here to set the record straight and hopefully provide a new perspective on the impact they have on our 20s, both from a scientific lens, but also reflecting on lived experience. I'm really excited to have on a lovely guest for this episode who will be joining us later on to discuss her own unique path to recovery. She was so incredibly vulnerable and insightful, so I cannot wait for you to hear from her,
而当它们受到关注时，往往是以一种被严重浪漫化、或者基于错误信息和污名化的方式。你知道的，我们都在电影和电视节目中看过对进食障碍的刻画。我们也见过社交媒体（从Tumblr到TikTok）是如何将饮食失调美化的，以及关于进食障碍流传着多少误解。所以我们今天来到这里，就是要拨乱反正，并希望能为它们对我们二十岁时的影响提供一个新的视角，既有科学的镜头，也反思亲身经历。我很兴奋能为这期节目邀请到一位可爱的嘉宾，她稍后会加入我们，讨论她独特的康复之路。她表现得极其脆弱又富有洞察力，所以我迫不及待想让你们听到她的分享，
but before we get to that, I really do want to give a bit of that birds eye view from a clinical, psychological perspective of what this class of disorders really is and what it means for people who are going through it, who are experiencing it, you know, not just anorexia and bulimia, which I think is what we typically think of, but also binge eating disorder and orthorexia. We're going to discuss the psychological underpinnings and the origins of eating disorders, whether they emerge from childhood or later triggering events, the different classes of eating disorders, and how they impact our emotional and psychological well-being,
但在我们进入正题之前，我真的想从临床心理学的宏观视角，来谈谈这类障碍究竟是什么，以及对于那些正在经历它、经受它的人来说意味着什么——不仅仅是我们通常想到的神经性厌食症和暴食症，还包括暴食障碍和健康饮食强迫症。我们将探讨进食障碍的心理学根源和起因，无论是源于童年还是后来的触发事件，进食障碍的不同类别，以及它们如何影响我们的情感和心理健康，
along with some of the opportunities for treatment and for recovery. We're also going to hear from Amalie a little bit later on. I think that having someone who has gone through this on the show is so valuable because we often only really, like I said, see it glamorized. So as always, there will be more information and links in the description of this episode. I'm just really excited to share a new perspective to share some of the science and some of the research. So without further ado, let's dive in and talk about the psychology behind eating disorders in our 20s. eating disorders may seem like a modern day condition that's kind of been created by recent social fixations with thinness and beauty and calories
以及治疗和康复的一些机会。稍后我们还会听到阿马莉的分享。我认为邀请一位经历过这一切的人来到节目中非常有价值，因为就像我说的，我们通常只能看到它被美化的一面。因此，一如既往，这期节目的简介中会有更多信息和链接。我真的很兴奋能分享一个新的视角，分享一些科学知识和研究成果。闲话少说，让我们深入探讨二十岁进食障碍背后的心理学。进食障碍看起来可能是一种现代疾病，某种程度上是由最近社会对消瘦、美貌和卡路里的迷恋所创造的，
but there is so much historical evidence they've existed for quite a while because they aren't just cultural or social constructs they are very serious mental health conditions that originate from our emotional and cognitive experiences not just our society's relationship with food at a given time. There are reports of people experiencing symptoms of what we would now label as anorexia or bulimia way back in the 5th century, you know, men and women starving themselves because of mental health conditions or for spiritual purposes
但有大量历史证据表明它们已经存在相当长一段时间了，因为它们不仅仅是文化或社会的建构，而是非常严重的心理健康问题，它们源于我们的情感和认知体验，而不仅仅是我们社会在特定时期的食物关系。早在公元5世纪，就有关于人们经历我们现在贴上厌食症或贪食症标签的症状的报告，你知道的，男男女女因为心理健康问题或出于精神目的而让自己挨饿，
before we even had a label for what they were going through. In fact, the first known name for anorexia it actually appeared in the 1600s and at the time it was called nervous consumption, which is a strange name for it, but the description of the symptoms, it really doesn't differ much from our current diagnostic profile. Eating disorders, as the name suggests, they are primary related to a class of mental health conditions that pertain to persistent eating habits, behaviours, and compulsions that negatively impact our health, our emotional state, and our general ability to kind of function
甚至在我们给他们所经历的事情起名字之前。事实上，厌食症最早为人所知的名字出现在17世纪，当时被称为“神经性消耗”，这个名字听起来很奇怪，但对症状的描述与我们当前的诊断标准实际上并没有太大区别。顾名思义，进食障碍是一类主要与持续性饮食习惯、行为和强迫症相关的心理健康状况，这些状况会对我们的健康、情绪状态以及在各个生活领域中发挥功能的一般能力产生负面影响
in all areas of our life. And they are most prevalent amongst people in their 20s. That is within the typical onset window. It's when, you know, symptoms, normally climax. And they're also really complex disorders and they're not all made the same. I also think that it's important to note that not all elements of these conditions are solely related to eating. You know, there is a massive, cognitive and emotional and mental component to their onset and longevity. It has a lot to do with exercise and a few other things, as we'll talk about. But there are three main eating disorders that we would typically say are the most common or that show up in the DSM. So the DSM is the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders.
而它们在二十多岁的人群中最普遍。这正处于典型的发作年龄窗口期。也就是症状通常达到顶峰的时候。而且它们也是非常复杂的障碍，每一种都不尽相同。我也认为重要的是要注意，这些病症的并非所有方面都纯粹与饮食有关。你知道，它们的爆发和持续有着巨大的认知、情感和心理因素。正如我们所讨论的，这与运动和其他一些事情有很大关系。但我们通常会说有三种主要的进食障碍是最常见的，或者会出现在DSM中。那么DSM是什么呢，它是《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》。
So if you haven't heard about it before, it's essentially like the Bible for all possible mental health conditions. And it's used by clinicians to kind of identify symptoms and provide an explanation to patients. Now, this does not mean that there are not other variations of these disorders. You know, there are only currently three eating disorders in the DSM. but just because other conditions or experiences or symptoms don't have a specific diagnosis, it doesn't mean that they don't exist. There can be variation. And it's actually a huge point of contention and debate around eating disorders and the use of the DSM.
所以如果你以前没听说过，它基本上就像是所有可能心理健康状况的圣经。临床医生用它来识别症状并为患者提供解释。现在，这并不意味着这些障碍没有其他变体。你知道，目前DSM中只有三种进食障碍。但仅仅因为其他病症、经历或症状没有具体的诊断，并不意味着它们不存在。可能存在变异。这实际上是围绕进食障碍和使用DSM的一个巨大争议和辩论点。
You know, not every condition is going to present in the exact same way, you know, with, everyone and having a simple list of criteria is often going to exclude some people who might not fit the mould but that is obviously a discussion for another time the three that do appear are anorexia nervosa bulimia nervosa and binge eating disorder so that's what we're going to talk about today i think the disorder that we typically think of when we hear the term eating disorder is anorexia On set is normally, you know, between the ages of 12 and 25, which is really heartbreaking to hear that, you know, children at 12 years old are experiencing this, but really anyone at any age is afflicted by this condition because it is so harsh. It's so harsh on our bodies and it's so hard on our minds. It's characterized by symptoms of extreme dieting, accompanied by an intense fear of gaining weight, having a disembate. stored body image, which essentially means that you don't see yourself the way other people see you. You don't see yourself clearly or objectively. And also drastic weight loss. Now, those are the
你知道，并不是每种病症在每个人身上都会以完全相同的方式表现出来，拥有一份简单的标准清单往往会排除了那些可能不符合模特的某些人，但这显然是另一个时候的讨论话题。确实出现的这三种是：神经性厌食症、神经性贪食症和暴食障碍，这就是我们今天要谈论的。我认为当我们听到进食障碍这个词时，通常想到的疾病是厌食症。发病通常在12到25岁之间，听到12岁的儿童正在经历这种痛苦真的让人心碎，但实际上任何年龄的任何人都会被这种疾病折磨，因为它太残酷了。它对我们的身体如此残酷，对我们的心理也如此艰难。其特征是极端节食的症状，伴随着对体重增加的强烈恐惧，以及扭曲的身体形象，这基本上意味着你看到自己的方式与其他人看到你的方式不同。你看不到清晰或客观的自己。还有急剧的体重减轻。现在，这些是
criteria given by the DSM. But drastic weight loss is not always a characteristic of all people with anorexia. And I think just because someone isn't underweight or thin, it doesn't mean that they're not suffering, you know, people have different metabolisms, different body structures and shapes. I think it's also worth noting that someone who has just started displaying symptoms of anorexia may still be what we deem a healthy body weight, but it doesn't mean that they aren't still experiencing distress and experiencing symptoms. These instances where someone is not what we would call underweight. It's known as atypical anorexia nervosa and it occurs in situations in which someone meets all the other qualifications. You know, they have restrictive eating. They might be exercising
DSM给出的标准。但急剧体重减轻并不总是所有厌食症患者的特征。我认为，仅仅因为一个人不是体重过轻或消瘦，并不意味着他们没有遭受痛苦，你知道的，人们有不同的新陈代谢、不同的身体结构和体型。我认为同样值得注意的是，刚刚开始表现出厌食症症状的人可能仍然处于我们认为健康的体重，但这并不意味着他们没有经历痛苦和症状。这些处于非我们称之为体重过轻的情况被称为非典型神经性厌食症，它发生在满足所有其他条件的情况下。你知道，他们有限制性饮食。他们可能在进行
excessively, but they're not currently underweight. And the thing to note is that the symptoms, the, you know, some of the other symptoms other than body weight between atypical anorexia and what we would say is typical anorexia, they're all still this. same. You know, we see food avoidance. We see obsessive compulsive symptoms. You know, for example, people with this disorder, they may have really ritualistic, compulsive eating habits or safe foods that they form an obsession over. They may have this need for a sense of control or what they put in their bodies. But they also have things like anxiety around food and social situations, which comes off as almost social anxiety or potentially a social.
过度的锻炼，但目前体重并不低。需要注意的是，除了体重之外，非典型厌食症和我们所说的典型厌食症的其他一些症状其实都是一样的。你知道，我们看到对食物的逃避。我们看到强迫症症状。例如，患有这种障碍的人可能有高度仪式化、强迫性的饮食习惯，或者对他们形成痴迷的安全食物。他们可能对放进身体里的东西有一种对掌控感的需求。但他们也有诸如对食物和社交场合的焦虑，这几乎表现为社交焦虑或者潜在的社交
social phobia, but also things like hair loss, chronic fatigue, insomnia, anemia. It impacts every facet of our health, not just physical. It's something to really remember. And someone doesn't have to appear thin to be experiencing anorexia. I think that's something that we really need to reframe, not just in the psychological community, but also within society. Anorexia is actually one of the most difficult psychiatric conditions to treat, not just in the class of eating disorders, but across the board. And it has one of the highest mortality rates associated with it
社交恐惧症，还有诸如脱发、慢性疲劳、失眠、贫血等问题。它影响着我们健康的方方面面，而不仅仅是生理上的。这是需要真正记住的一点。而且一个人不需要看起来消瘦就能经历厌食症。我认为这是我们需要重新构建的一种观念，不仅在心理学界，在整个社会中也是如此。厌食症实际上是最难以治疗的精神疾病之一，不仅在进食障碍这一类中，而且在所有精神疾病中都是如此。并且它拥有最高的死亡率之一
because this level of dieting puts our body under such intense strain. And it becomes an addiction. These methods for weight loss become coping mechanisms and they become reinforced when people see, what they deem as results. And what essentially happens is that the more they are almost internally and subconsciously rewarded for their behaviors and for their habits, the more ingrained it becomes, the more reliant they become. And it's also a substitute for control over other areas of their life. So it's hard to break free on. I don't really want that statement to
因为这种程度的节食让我们的身体承受了极大的压力。并且它变成了一种瘾。这些减肥方法变成了应对机制，当人们看到他们认为是成果的东西时，这些方法就会得到强化。基本上发生的情况是，他们对自己的行为和习惯得到的内部和潜意识的奖励越多，它就越根深蒂固，他们就越依赖它。这也是对生活中其他领域控制权的一种替代。所以很难从中解脱。我其实不想让这句话
seem like it's meant to discourage people. You know, there are so many people. who have and do and will recover, but it is really worth noting. Also, it's quite interesting because despite being, I think, the most thought of eating disorder, it's actually the least common amongst those diagnosed with this condition. So only 3% of people who are diagnosed with an eating disorder would have what we would call anorexia. The most common is actually binge eating disorder at nearly 47% followed by bulimia at 12%. So it's interesting that I think when we think eating disorder, we typically think of someone who is very thin and who starves themselves, which is of course a very much valid part of the community, but it's also important to focus on
听起来像是要打击大家。你知道，有那么多的人已经、正在并且将会康复，但这一点确实值得注意。另外，这相当有趣，尽管我认为这是人们最常想到的进食障碍，但它实际上是被诊断患有此病的人中最不常见的一种。因此，只有3%被诊断患有进食障碍的人患有所谓的厌食症。最常见的是暴食障碍，占近47%，其次是贪食症，占12%。所以很有趣，我认为当我们想到进食障碍时，通常会想到一个非常消瘦、让自己挨饿的人，这当然是该群体中非常真实的一部分，但关注
some of the other conditions that people may have. So let's talk about bulimia first. Bulimia has a later typical onset than anorexia at around 20 years of age and it does often begin with excessive dieting before we kind of see that slide into what the typical symptoms of bulimia may be. So that is the binging and then purging or fasting that is characteristic of this disorder. So what essentially happens and what people would probably be looking out for if they thought someone was suffering from this is an instance or a repeated pattern of behaviour in which someone rapidly consumes food before entering into a period where they try and expel or burn those calories as quick as possible, either through the methods we typically think of, but also by taking lack of. by avoiding water or excessive sweating like in a sauna or a steam room. Like anorexia, this disorder is also accompanied by an excessive concern about body weight or appearance. And it follows this cycle of kind of normalcy in which someone feels like they're in control and then a temporary loss of control when consuming excessive amounts of food, followed by anxiety, by guilt, by fear even, and then relief when they are able to purge those calories
人们可能患有的其他一些疾病也很重要。所以我们先来谈谈贪食症。贪食症的典型发病年龄比厌食症晚，大约在20岁左右，而且它通常在开始出现贪食症典型症状之前，伴随着过度节食。这就是该障碍特征性的暴食然后催吐或禁食。所以基本上发生的事情，以及如果人们认为有人患有此病可能会注意到的事情，是某种行为的发生或重复模式，即一个人在进入试图以尽可能快的方式排出或消耗这些卡路里的时期之前迅速消耗食物，这可以通过我们通常想到的方法，也可以通过缺乏水或过度排汗来实现，比如在桑拿房或蒸汽房里。像厌食症一样，这种障碍也伴随着对体重或外表的过度关注。它遵循这样一种循环：一个人在某种程度上感到自己能掌控，然后在消耗大量食物时暂时失去控制，随后是焦虑、内疚、甚至恐惧，而当他们能够将这些卡路里排出体外时，就会感到解脱
from their system. And that cycle is what makes this disorder so troubling, because it involves the use of food to regulate mood. And it's an important link between all of these disorders. It's not just about food. It's about the use of food. as a means for control. People who are living with this disorder, they will often experience a number of other health problems and symptoms like abnormal heart rhythms due to an electrolyte imbalance from binging and purging,
从他们的系统中。正是这种循环使得这种障碍如此令人困扰，因为它涉及利用食物来调节情绪。这是所有这些障碍之间的一个重要联系。这不仅仅关于食物。这是关于食物的使用
dental issues from the enamel on their teeth being worn down by the acidic acid that comes from their stomach, nutrient imbalances, and a regular menstrual cycle, which is also typical of anaerrifice. Porexia, fatigue, burnout, exhaustion, heartburn, ulcers and anxiety, depression, so many other things. It's also accompanied by delusions a lot of the time and this preoccupation with how we look and what we would call is body dysmorphia. So a failure to clearly see what other people see when they look at us.
作为一种控制手段。患有这种障碍的人通常会经历许多其他健康问题和症状，如暴食和催吐导致的电解质失衡引起的心律异常，因胃酸磨损牙釉质而导致的牙齿问题，营养失衡，以及不规律的月经周期，这也是厌食症的典型特征。厌食、疲劳、职业倦怠、精疲力竭、胃灼热、溃疡和焦虑、抑郁以及许多其他问题。它还经常伴随着妄想，以及对我们外表的过度关注，也就是我们所说的身体变形障碍。也就是无法清晰地看到别人看我们时的样子。
and it has a really close relationship with our self-esteem, with our sense of agency, with our sense of security, with our self-worth. Bulimia is an interesting disorder because it's actually been suggested across multiple studies that certain individuals may actually have an inherited or genetic predisposition, whereby if you have a close relative or a parent who was diagnosed with bulimia nervosa, there is between like a 50 to 80% chance that you're more likely to develop symptoms. This is a really interesting insight to me because I think that it shows that these disorders are not just individual, they're not just behavioral, but they also have a lot to do with our genetic blueprint and how our minds operate.
它与我们的自尊、我们的自主感、我们的安全感、我们的自我价值有着极其紧密的联系。贪食症是一种有趣的疾病，多项研究表明，某些人实际上可能具有遗传或基因易感性，如果你有患有神经性贪食症的近亲或父母，你患上这种症状的可能性大约在50%到80%之间。这对我来说是一个非常有趣的见解，因为我认为它表明这些障碍不仅仅是个体的，不仅仅是行为上的，它们还与我们的基因蓝图以及我们的思维运作方式有很大关系。
Let's talk about binge eating disorder. You know, binge eating disorder is actually a relatively newly recognized condition. It's only really been in the DSM for the past five to ten years, which is so surprising to me because nowadays it is more diagnosed. It's more common than breast cancer. It's more common than HIV. It's more common than schizophrenia. But it hasn't always gotten the recognition that. it deserves. And I think that really shows how the medical community can sometimes be quite slow to
我们来谈谈暴食障碍。你知道，暴食障碍实际上是一种相对较新被认识到的疾病。它进入DSM仅仅只有过去五到十年的时间，这让我感到非常惊讶，因为如今它被诊断得更多了。它比乳腺癌更常见。它比艾滋病更常见。它比精神分裂症更常见。但它并没有总是得到它应有的认可。我认为这确实表明医疗界有时可能会相当迟钝
catch up because I think binge eating disorder, unlike anorexia and unlike bulimia, it's not glamorous. And I hate to use that word, but glamorous in the sense that there's part of it that is accepted by society. You know, we accept diet culture as part of society. But we don't accept. We're very judgmental around people who we deem as overweight. With this disorder, I think it's really important to distinguish between occasional overeating and a binge eating disorder. You know, we all have times when we eat past the point of being full, you know, maybe at Christmas or on birthdays or just because the food is really yum. But in those instances, it's not a compulsion. You have control. It's also not a repeated behavior.
赶上来，因为我认为暴食障碍与厌食症和贪食症不同，它并不光鲜亮丽。我讨厌用这个词，但说它光鲜是因为它的一部分是被社会接受的。你知道，我们接受节食文化作为社会的一部分。但我们不接受。我们对我们认为超重的人非常评判。对于这种疾病，我认为区分偶尔的暴饮暴食和暴食障碍非常重要。你知道，我们都有过吃得超过饱腹感的时候，你知道，也许是在圣诞节、生日，或者只是因为食物真的很美味。但在这些情况下，这不是一种强迫。你有控制力。它也不是一种重复的行为。
It's not life altering. It doesn't feel like something that you can't stop. And I think that's a really important distinction to make. Some of the other core symptoms include eating unusually large amounts of food, often by yourself or in isolation because of the associated guilt and the associated shame, eating until you are uncomfortable or feel disgusted, feeling like you have no control. And like so many of these disorders that we've talked about, it's often accompanied by social isolation, by problems functioning in your personal life and occasionally weight-related conditions,
它不会改变生活。它不会让你觉得有什么是你停不下来的。我认为这是一个非常重要的区别。其他一些核心症状包括吃异常大量的食物，由于随之而来的内疚和羞耻感，通常独自一人或在隔离状态下进食，吃到感到不舒服或恶心，觉得自己完全失去了控制。就像我们讨论过的许多这些障碍一样，它通常伴随着社交隔离、个人生活功能受损以及偶尔与体重相关的状况，
although that's not always the case. It's much more likely that people who are experiencing binge eating disorder may, and be deemed a normal weight and putting that in quotation marks because I think that is very much up for debate what a normal weight means and unlike other disorders we've spoken of today binge eating disorder actually has a much later onset so for women it's in their early to late 20s and for men it's most typical and onset typically begins during middle age which is really interesting because I think that we have this misconception that our late teens and our early 20s are the time when eating disorders are most prevalent. But that's really only the case for bulimia and anorexia, which is why I think binge eating disorder is often misunderstood or often not thought of when we think about this class of conditions.
尽管情况并非总是如此。经历暴食障碍的人更有可能被认为处于正常体重（这里加上引号，因为我认为正常体重的含义非常值得商榷），并且与我们今天讨论的其他障碍不同，暴食障碍的发病要晚得多——对于女性来说是在20岁出头到快30岁，而对于男性来说最典型，通常在中年开始发病，这真的很有趣，因为我认为我们有一种误解，即青少年晚期和二十岁出头是进食障碍最普遍的时期。但这真的只适用于贪食症和厌食症，这就是为什么我认为当我们想到这类疾病时，暴食障碍经常被误解或被忽视。
there are some really amazing content creators and TikTokers out there who really take us along for their recovery journey and I think it's really worthwhile to see these people in the media even if it's social media because it's important to humanize this disorder and understand it better because there are some really brutal misconceptions that you know it's just for people who have no control or who struggle with their weight and it isn't really a disorder but it really is it's diagnosable and so i think that i would really encourage you to look into the lived experience of people with binge eating disorder it's just so valuable to really understand where it sits i want to quickly mention orthorexia so we don't have that much time to really deep dive into it, but I think it's so worth mentioning
有一些非常棒的内容创作者和TikTok博主，他们真正带我们了解他们的康复历程，我认为在媒体上看到这些人是非常值得的，即使是社交媒体，因为将这种疾病人性化并更好地理解它是很重要的，因为有一些非常残忍的误解，认为这只是针对那些没有控制力或与体重作斗争的人，它并不是真正的障碍，但它确实是，它是可诊断的，所以我真的会鼓励你了解暴食障碍患者的亲身体验，了解它处于什么位置真的非常有价值。我想快速提一下健康饮食强迫症，我们没有那么多时间深入探讨它，但我认为在这里提出来非常值得
here because it's a relatively new idea or a relatively new condition. So it was only introduced back in 1997. It's still not in the DSM, but it's become so much more prevalent recently. So orthorexia, it's also known as clean eating disorder or an unhealthy obsessive. with eating healthy and only consuming what we see as clean foods, normally in an effort to maintain one's weight or because of this obsession with optimal nutrition to the point where it negatively impacts our well-being. It's not completely understood. Like I said, it's relatively new in the scheme of things, but initial theories have linked to it to things like OCD, obsessive compulsive disorder, health anxiety, and this extreme
因为它是一个相对较新的想法或相对较新的疾病。所以它是在1997年才被引入的。它仍然没有进入DSM，但最近变得越来越普遍。所以，健康饮食强迫症，也被称为干净饮食障碍或对健康饮食的不健康痴迷，只摄入我们认为干净的食物，通常是为了保持体重，或者是由于对最佳营养的这种痴迷，以至于对我们的幸福感产生负面影响。它并没有被完全理解。就像我说的，在宏观计划中它是比较新的，但最初的理论将其与强迫症（OCD）、健康焦虑等问题联系起来，这种极端
fixation on the purity or cleanliness of what we put in our bodies. Eating disorders often develop in our teen and younger years, although we know that that's not always the case in all circumstances, and there are a number of researched and hypothesized kind of psychological and environmental or social origins or triggers for eating disorders, ranging from our early childhood experiences to other mental health disorders like anxiety, parental upbringing, and even genetics like we mentioned before. So let's actually start with genetics. We know a lot of mental health disorders like bipolar, depression, anxiety,
对我们体内摄入物质的纯净度或清洁度的执着。进食障碍通常在我们的青少年时期和更年轻的时候发展，尽管我们知道在所有情况下并非总是如此，并且有许多经过研究和假设的心理和环境或社交起源或进食障碍的触发因素，从我们的早年童年经历到其他心理健康障碍，如焦虑、父母养育方式，甚至像我们之前提到的基因。所以让我们从基因开始。我们知道许多心理健康障碍，如双相情感障碍、抑郁症、焦虑症，
even schizophrenia, they are more common amongst people who have a close relative who has received a diagnosis. And the same goes for bulimia, the same goes for anorexia and for binge eating disorder. There appears to be some genetic predisposition amongst individuals who experience symptoms. And this also has a lot to do with the release of neurotransmitters, like serotonin and dopamine, which we know is controlled by our genetic blueprint. So studies have shown that people with anorexia or binge eating disorder, they actually may have less serotonin available to their brain. And this impacts things like impulse control.
甚至是精神分裂症，在有被诊断出该病的近亲的人中更常见。贪食症、厌食症和暴食障碍也是如此。在经历症状的个体中，似乎存在某种基因易感性。这与神经递质（如血清素和多巴胺）的释放也有很大关系，我们知道这是由我们的基因蓝图控制的。因此研究表明，患有厌食症或暴食障碍的人，他们大脑中可用的血清素实际上可能更少。这会影响诸如冲动控制之类的事情。
It impacts things like our relationship with reward, like gratification and therefore our eating habits. There have been some suggestions that this heritability hypothesis, it isn't about biology. It's about exposure. You know, if you have a parent who restricts food, who constantly talks about their weight, you pick up on that because of your close environmental proximity.
它影响诸如我们与奖励的关系之类的事情，比如满足感，从而影响我们的饮食习惯。有人提出，这种遗传度假设并非关乎生物学。而是关于暴露。你知道，如果你有一个限制食物、经常谈论体重的父母，由于你们密切的环境接近性，你会注意到这一点。
And a lot of people think that it's not so much biology, but it's about your environment. But there have been studies that have shown, you know, people who have been adopted, who weren't raised with their birth parents or twins who have been separated at birth, their likelihood of developing an eating disorder is genetically linked. But it is an important, I think, factor to bring up here. Our social environment is going to be a massive contributor,
很多人认为这与其说是生物学问题，不如说是环境问题。但已经有研究表明，被收养、没有由亲生父母抚养长大的人，或者在出生时被分开的双胞胎，他们患进食障碍的可能性与基因有关。但我认为，这是一个需要在这里提出的重要因素。我们的社会环境将是一个巨大的贡献者，
not just our close family, but our friends. Our school environment, the broader context of our cultural and social. societal environment as well. And it begins young. It begins really young. If close parental or family figures have modeled an unhealthy relationship towards food, whatever that may be, we learn from that. We pick up that behavior. These people are our teachers. They are our role models. And we mimic what they do. You know, if, your family is constantly making comments about your weight or someone else's weight about the food you're eating, the food they're eating, how your clothes don't, you know, fit right, how you need to be
不仅是我们亲近的家人，还有我们的朋友。我们的学校环境，我们的文化和社会环境的更广泛背景也是如此。而且它从年轻时就开始了。它真的很年轻就开始了。如果亲近的父母或家庭成员对食物树立了不健康的关系，无论那可能是什么，我们都会从中学习。我们模仿这种行为。这些人是我们的老师。他们是我们的榜样。我们模仿他们的所作所为。你知道，如果你的家人经常对你的体重或别人的体重、你吃的食物、他们吃的食物、你的衣服如何不合身、你如何需要
strict with what you put in your body, that passes on to us. Other research even suggests that childhood bullying is also a massive predictor, but not just amongst kids who experience bullying, but also kids who have bullied. You know, it's always that saying that the bullied becomes the bully, right? Like, the same reasons why someone who's been bullied might develop an eating disorder are the same for those of people who do bully. It's a self-esteem thing. And I think also the opinions of our peers are deeply influential and deeply harmful. at a young age when we are so vulnerable. But it also comes from even more insidious and inescapable sources like the media.
严格控制你摄入体内的东西，这就会传递给我们。其他研究甚至表明，童年欺凌也是一个巨大的预测指标，不仅在经历欺凌的孩子中，而且在欺凌别人的孩子中也是如此。你知道，总有那样一句话，被欺凌者变成了欺凌者，对吧？就像，经历过欺凌的人可能患有进食障碍的原因，与那些确实欺凌别人的人是一样的。这是一个自尊的问题。而且我认为同龄人的意见也极具影响力和极具危害性。在我们如此脆弱的年轻时候。但它也来自甚至更隐蔽和不可逃避的来源，比如媒体。
I think especially in Western cultures like Australia, there are so many sociocultural influences that promote thinness as the main indicator of beauty, as a contributor to our happiness, as a desirable trait. And with that, it also promotes, an unhealthy relationship with food, like crash diets, like fasting and calorie counting. Repeated exposure to this rhetoric, to this perspective, it unconsciously feeds into how we see ourselves and not only our relationships with our bodies, but also with exercise and with our food. These environmental and social causes are often the most common triggers I think we think about,
我认为特别是在澳大利亚这样的西方文化中，有太多的社会文化影响将消瘦推广为美的主要指标、快乐的促进者、一种令人向往的特质。随之而来的是，它还促进了与食物的不健康关系，比如急救节食、禁食和卡路里计算。反复接触这种言论、这种观点，无意识地助长了我们如何看待自己，不仅是我们与身体的关系，还有我们与运动和食物的关系。这些环境和社会原因往往是我们认为最常见的触发因素，
but it can be a lot more complicated and nuanced than that. There are certainly personality traits that greatly influence the development of these conditions, things that have to do with our psychology, things that have to do with our mental health, our emotional state. One of these is OCD, so obsessive-compulsive disorder. Like we've mentioned before, this is a tendency to obsess and have intrusive thoughts. So obsessive, compulsive disorder is the kind of experience of obsessions and compulsions that bring about a sense of control. And when we think about how that relates to eating disorders, a lot of the eating habits that we've spoken about, it's not about food.
但它可能比那要复杂和细致得多。当然有一些人格特征极大地影响了这些疾病的发展，这些特征与我们的心理学、我们的心理健康、我们的情绪状态有关。其中之一就是强迫症（OCD），也就是强迫性神经症。就像我们之前提到的，这是一种强迫和产生侵入性想法的倾向。因此，强迫症是强迫观念和强迫行为的一种体验，它带来了一种控制感。当我们思考这与进食障碍的关系时，我们所讨论的许多饮食习惯并不是关于食物。
It's not always about the calories. It's not always about weight. It's about using food as a means to bring about control in our lives, especially if you are someone, who has experienced trauma or PTSD. If you never felt like you had power in those situations, food can become a substitute for the control that you wish you had. Perfectionism is another major contributor, especially in people with anorexia.
它并不总是关于卡路里。它并不总是关于体重。它是关于利用食物作为在我们的生活中带来控制的一种手段，特别是如果你是一个经历过创伤或创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的人。如果你觉得自己在那些情况下从未有过权力，食物就可以成为你希望拥有的控制权的替代品。完美主义是另一个主要贡献者，特别是在厌食症患者中。
So there is research suggesting that it is an overly represented personality trait amongst these individuals, alongside things like low self-esteem, low self-worth, loneliness, anger, anxiety, all of those emotional experiences can be projected onto something within our control, and that is what we eat, what we put in our body. It's not just one thing, though, it's not just one factor. It's a risk profile. It's a series of things that come together. and can be triggered by an event or by our environment, and that leads to this pattern of symptoms that we associated with eating disorders.
所以有研究表明，它是这些个体中过度代表的人格特征，此外还有低自尊、低自我价值、孤独、愤怒、焦虑等，所有这些情感体验都可以投射到我们控制范围内的事情上，那就是我们吃什么，我们放进身体里的东西。但这并不是单一的事情，它不仅仅是一个因素。这是一个风险概况。这是一系列融合在一起的事情，并且可能会被事件或我们的环境触发，从而导致与进食障碍相关的症状模式。
I think it's really easy to feel like a lot of this is outside our control. You know, eating disorders are so insidious and difficult to treat at times because it's not as simple as beauty standards. It's inextricably linked to our emotional and mental state. that's why they're called disorders and i think it also just goes to show how misunderstood um this class of conditions can be there is so much misinformation out there so much unscientific opinions and research so many random people trying to give advice and i think sometimes it's important to take a step back and really look at what the science and the research has to say and hear about people
我认为很容易让人觉得很多事情都在我们的控制之外。你知道，进食障碍有时是如此隐蔽且难以治疗，因为这不像审美标准那么简单。它与我们的情感和精神状态密不可分。这就是为什么它们被称为障碍，我认为这也恰恰说明了这类病症被误解得有多深，嗯。外面有太多的错误信息、太多的非科学观点和研究、太多的随机人群试图给出建议，我认为有时重要的是退后一步，真正看看科学和研究怎么说，并听听那些
who have actually gone through this, hear from someone with a real life perspective. So that's what I want to do next. I want to bring on our special guest to talk us through how anorexia manifested for her, how it impacted her teen years, her 20s, and her path to healing and recovery. I am so excited to be able to bring on our amazing guest, Amalia, who is, the host of the recovery talk podcast. It's incredible. Additionally, she works as an eating disorder recovery coach and just makes some amazing, amazing content, has some amazing lived experience and some amazing insights. Welcome. Welcome to the show. Thank you so much for having me.
真正经历过这一切的人的看法，听听具有现实生活视角的人怎么说。所以这正是我接下来想做的。我想请我们的特邀嘉宾来跟我们谈谈厌食症是如何在她身上表现出来的，它如何影响了她的青少年时期、二十岁，以及她走向治愈和康复的道路。我非常高兴能够请到我们惊艳的嘉宾阿马莉（Amalia），她是《康复谈话》（Recovery Talk）播客的主持人。这太不可思议了。此外，她还是一名进食障碍康复教练，创作了一些非常棒的内容，拥有一些惊人的亲身经历和精彩的见解。欢迎。欢迎来到节目。非常感谢邀请我。
Yeah, of course. I feel like your way of talking about not only your eating disorder, but as a class of mental health conditions is really, really refreshing. So I was like, I've got to have you on. I really want to start the beginning. So you run this amazing podcast called Recovery Talk. And what kind of inspired you to kind of begin that? So 10 years ago, wow, it's been a while, 10 years ago, I was going through my own eating disorder recovery.
对，当然。我觉得你谈论进食障碍的方式，不仅作为一类心理健康状况，而且非常非常令人耳目一新。所以我当时就想：我一定要把你请来。我真的想从头开始。所以你主持了这个名为《康复谈话》的精彩播客。是什么启发你开始这个项目的？所以10年前，哇，已经过去一段时间了，10年前，我正在经历我自己的进食障碍康复。
I was recovering from anorexin of a binge approach subtype. and my treatment was pretty good, but I was told a lot what to do, but not why. And I'm a person that's so I love science. I like knowing why is this happening to me. Why do I need to do this, right? I wanted to know the science of eating disorder recovery, right? And I didn't necessarily get that from my treatment. So I essentially started heavily researching eating disorders.
我当时正在从神经性厌食症暴食清除亚型中恢复。我的治疗相当不错，但我被告知了很多该做什么，而不是为什么。而我是一个这样的人——我热爱科学。我喜欢知道为什么这会发生在我身上。为什么我需要这样做，对吧？我想知道进食障碍康复的科学原理，对吧？而我并没有从我的治疗中必然得到这一点。所以我基本上开始深入研究进食障碍。
And I found so many things, so many studies, so many articles that were so helpful for me. but they were all very, what I'm going to say, very scientific. And at that point, also English is my second language, especially 10 years ago. My English was, it was okay, but it wasn't completely fluent. So a lot of it was very difficult to understand. And I had a bit of an audience because I've been sharing my eating disorder recovery journey on Instagram. So I had a bit of an audience there. And I was like, wouldn't it be great to take this very scientific, a little bit difficult to understand content about eating disorders and the biology of eating disorders, right?
我找到了很多东西，很多研究，很多文章，对我都很有帮助。但它们都非常，我该怎么说呢，非常科学。而且当时，英语也是我的第二语言，尤其是10年前。我的英语，还行，但还算不上非常流利。所以很多内容很难理解。我在Instagram上分享过自己饮食失调康复的经历，所以当时已经有了一点粉丝基础。我在想，如果把这些关于饮食失调以及饮食失调生物学的、非常科学且有点难以理解的内容……
and share that with more people. So I started a platform called Let's Recovery, started as a Tumblr, and I would essentially take these studies such as, for example, Minnesota Starvation Study and studies about eating disorders and translate them to a little bit easier to understand language and share them with a lot of people. And that became very popular. And then one thing led to another and eventually I started a podcast,
分享给更多人，不是很好吗？于是我创办了一个名为“Let's Recovery”的平台，一开始是个Tumblr博客，我基本上会把这些研究——比如明尼苏达饥饿实验以及关于饮食失调的研究——翻译成更容易理解的语言，分享给很多人。这个平台变得非常受欢迎。后来机缘巧合，我最终创办了一个播客，
essentially doing the same thing. Talking about the science and psychology of eating disorders from a lived experience and also as an experience as an eating disorder recovery coach and also someone who has a psychology degree as well. So I'm using a bit of different, what can I say, I come to the topic in different ways and angles. And I absolutely love that because I feel like that's a perfect intersection with what we kind of do on this show, right? Like there are all these sometimes very inaccessible scientific ideas or topics that have a lot of impact on our daily lives. So I, I absolutely love that. I really want to understand what your eating disorder kind of means to you. Can you
基本上也是在做同样的事情。从亲身经历的角度，以及作为一名饮食失调康复教练和拥有心理学学位的人的角度，来探讨饮食失调的科学和心理学。所以我会运用一些不同的，怎么说呢，我从不同的方式和角度切入这个话题。我非常喜欢这样，因为我觉得这与我们在本期节目中所做的事情完美契合，对吧？就像所有这些有时非常晦涩难懂的科学理念或话题，其实对我们的日常生活有着巨大的影响。所以，我，我真的很喜欢这样。我非常想了解你的饮食失调对你来说意味着什么。你能……
briefly maybe explain your eating disorder for those of us who might not be fully across what anorexia nervosa is and the difference between that and bulimia and other disorders? So I started developing an eating disorder when I was in my teens and it was kind of fluctuating a bit between different eating disorders, which is maybe one thing that people could be aware of is that an eating disorder, tend to very often create very strong separations between anorexia, bulimia, binge eating disorder, but actually very often they overlap, right? So I had anorexia and a nivosa binge purge subtype is my diagnosis, which essentially mean that it is predominantly anorexia and very significant restriction, but also having elements of binging and then purging afterwards, right?
简单地解释一下什么是饮食失调吗？针对我们当中可能不太完全了解神经性厌食症是什么，以及它与贪食症和其他失调症的区别的人？我是在十几岁的时候开始出现饮食失调的，病情在不同的饮食失调症之间有些摇摆不定，人们可能需要意识到的一点是，饮食失调症往往会在厌食症、贪食症、暴食症之间划清界限，但实际上它们经常是重叠的，对吧？我的诊断是神经性厌食症伴随暴食/催吐型，这基本上意味着它主要是厌食症，有非常严重的节食限制，但也有暴食以及随后的催吐行为，对吧？
So it's kind of like anorexia and bulimia overlapping. I started developing that in my teens, and I was very, very sick. I was very, very isolated. I was very unwell, but also a little bit in denial of how bad my eating disorder was. And this is also something interestingly enough that turns out to be a key symptom of an eating disorder is that people with eating disorder tend to be in denial of the severity of their illness and also about the fact that the illness exists in the first place, right? So I was really struggling, but thankfully, eventually I got into treatment and it was very, very, it was rough, right?
所以它有点像厌食症和贪食症的结合。我从十几岁开始出现这种情况，当时病得非常非常重。我非常非常孤立。我状况很糟，但同时也对饮食失调有多严重有点否认。有趣的是，这也是饮食失调的一个关键症状，患有饮食失调的人往往会否认病情的严重性，也会否认这种疾病本身的存在，对吧？我当时真的很痛苦，但幸运的是，我最终接受了治疗，而且过程非常非常艰难，对吧？
What did outpatient treatment? And yeah, I have been recovered now for 10 years. And it is difficult to understand exactly why I develop an eating disorder and what it was about. Very often when, especially when you come out on the other end of having recovered from an eating disorder, you want to know, okay, what was that all about? right why did that happen and i eventually i think it was a combination of factors that made me vulnerable um i was quite depressed um i had a bad mental health during that time which made me more vulnerable i was struggling with you know my body image very common when someone is in their teams and then i also think that part of it was also this is where the more scientific part of
我接受了门诊治疗？是的，我现在已经康复10年了。要确切理解我为什么会患上饮食失调以及这到底是怎么回事，其实很难。通常情况下，特别是当你从饮食失调中康复走出来之后，你会想知道，好吧，这到底是怎么回事？为什么会这样？最后我觉得这是让我变得脆弱的多种因素的组合，嗯，我当时相当抑郁，那段时间我的心理健康状况很差，这让我变得更加脆弱；我在跟自己的身体形象作斗争，这在青少年中非常普遍；然后我还认为，部分原因也是——这就涉及到比较科学的部分了——
it come in there seems that i had a very abnormal reaction to undernourishment right so people So people with anorexia, when they end up in an undernourished state, it tends to set off what I tend to call a switch, right, where a person with anorexia will be rewarded for engaging in, you know, very restrictive behaviors, which for people without inorexia, would not be rewarding at all, right? So essentially becomes a bit of a vicious cycle where my brain would reward me for engaging in very restrictive behaviors
它似乎表明我对营养不良有着非常不正常的反应，对吧？所以，患有厌食症的人，当他们最终陷入营养不良的状态时，往往会触发我倾向于称之为“开关”的东西，对吧？患有厌食症的人会因为进行非常严格的限制行为而获得奖励，而这种行为对于没有厌食症的人来说根本没有任何奖励可言，对吧？所以这基本上变成了一个恶性循环，我的大脑会因为我进行非常严格的限制行为而奖励我，
combined with a denial of the fact that I was that ill in the first, place, right? And then it just became, I was very stuck, right? Become very stuck in your state and your brain is so undernourge. You can't quite think clearly either, right? I think that's a really interesting perspective to bring in terms of the interactions between risk factors. So you talked about, you had other predisposing mental health conditions, but also how the condition is almost promoted by that undernourishment, right?
再加上对病情其实没那么严重的否认，对吧？然后就变成了，我被困住了，对吧？你会深深地陷入那种状态，而且你的大脑营养极度不良。你也无法清晰地思考，对吧？我认为这是一个非常有趣的视角，展示了风险因素之间的相互作用。所以你提到过，你之前有其他易感的心理健康状况，但这种状况几乎是由这种营养不良所推动的，对吧？
Like it is that vicious cycle, that vicious interaction that I think a lot of us, when we hear about eating disorders and we don't have that knowledge or that lived experience or haven't practiced in treating eating disorders, don't really understand how nuanced and difficult that interaction was. So you developed anorexia. You said like in your late teens, early teens? Late teens, yes. Late teens. And how did that kind of impact your life? You know, I think often what we forget is that it's not like everything else in your life disappears and it's just a disorder, but maybe it does feel like that. So what kind of impact
就像这是一个恶性循环，这种恶性的相互作用，我想我们很多人在听到饮食失调，却没有这方面的知识、亲身经历或治疗饮食失调的实践经验时，并不能真正理解这种相互作用是多么微妙和艰难。所以你患上了厌食症。你刚才说是在青春期晚期、青少年早期？青春期晚期，是的。青春期晚期。那对你的生活有什么影响呢？你知道，我觉得我们经常忘记的是，这并不是说你生活中的其他一切都消失了，只剩下一个失调症，但也许感觉确实如此。那么它产生了什么样的影响……
did it have on you? I felt that the food restriction essentially brought on just life restriction, right? I was very, very isolated because at that point, the eating disorder became my only friend, right it was i was when you're that undernourished you it's very difficult to you know engage in life engage in friendships engage in studies in the same way that you would if you were renourished right and of course different people have different levels of function right there are some people who can be very very severe with an eating disorder but they may be completely able to you know keep a job right or do well in studies in the way that it affected me probably the most was just the isolation, right? I completely lost interest in the outer world. All I was interested in was
对你有什么影响？我觉得食物限制基本上带来了生活的限制，对吧？我非常非常孤立，因为在那时，饮食失调成了我唯一的“朋友”，对吧？当我营养不良到这种程度时，你很难，你知道的，去参与生活，去维系友谊，去像营养充足时那样进行学习，对吧？当然，不同的人有不同的功能水平，有些人饮食失调非常严重，但他们可能完全能够，你知道的，保住工作，或者在学业上表现良好。而它对我的影响，可能最大的一点就是孤立，对吧？我完全失去了对外在世界的兴趣。我感兴趣的只有……
food. The food obsession was extremely strong. And this is actually interestingly enough, very much a, actually a response to the starvation, right? You see people when they're very starved, they become very, very interested in food, right? And food seeking behavior, not necessarily always eating, but things such as cooking for others, obsession with food, very, very interested in food. That became my life, right? That was the only thing that I found interesting. So very, very isolated, but in a way, I didn't realize how isolated I was because it felt like, oh yeah, but I don't like being around other people, right?
食物。对食物的执念极其强烈。有趣的是，这实际上很大程度上是对饥饿的一种反应，对吧？你会发现人们在极度饥饿时，会对食物变得非常非常感兴趣，对吧？会有寻食行为，不一定总是进食，而是比如为别人做饭、对食物痴迷、对食物非常非常感兴趣。这就成了我的生活，对吧？那是唯一我觉得有趣的事情。所以非常非常孤立，但在某种程度上，我并没有意识到自己有多孤立，因为感觉就像是，哦，是的，但我就是不喜欢和别人在一起，对吧？
And don't get me wrong, I'm a big introverts. But during my eating disorder, I just couldn't have meaningful relationship with other people because I was so consumed with my eating disorder. That's really, it's quite sad, really, that it takes over so many other parts of your life. And I think that obsession with food thing is also. it's kind of like common sense, right? Like if you're starving your body, your body is immediately going to be seeking out that nutrition
别误会，我是个地道的内向者。但在我饮食失调期间，我就是无法与他人建立有意义的关系，因为我被饮食失调彻底吞噬了。这真的很令人悲伤，它竟然接管了你生活中的那么多部分。而且我觉得这种对食物的执念也是……这有点像是常识，对吧？如果你让身体挨饿，你的身体就会立即开始寻找营养，
and creating obsessions. The other interesting thing that I came across, like researching this was this idea of safe foods, particularly for people with anorexia. And we talked about it a bit briefly before, but can you explain that a little bit more? Because I feel like that's such an interesting part of this disorder that isn't really spoken about much.
并产生执念。我偶然发现的另一个有趣的事情，在研究这个课题时，就是“安全食物”的概念，特别是对于患有厌食症的人。我们之前简单聊过这个，你能再多解释一下吗？因为我觉得这是这种疾病中一个非常有趣、但却很少被谈论的部分。
Yes. So with anorexia and also with certain other eating disorders as well, it's very common that the amount of foods that the person, like the type of foods the person can eat without extreme fear, guilt and anxiety response really, really shrinks, right? So maybe someone starts cutting out certain foods and then they just cut out more and more to the point where they only have a very small amount of so-called safe foods, right? And safe foods are essentially foods that the person, can eat often in, again, limited amounts, without as much anxiety as certain other foods, right? Sometimes there still could be anxiety even eating the so-called safe foods, right? So that is essentially what safe food is. I had during the worst of my eating disorder, my, what can I say? The amount of safe foods I had was so, so small that it was just you can't really sustain human life, right? And interesting enough, when you really, really restrict your foods to very few foods, then what is very natural is that you're going to start, you know, binging on foods that are
是的。对于厌食症以及某些其他饮食失调症来说，非常常见的情况是，一个人能够吃的食物分量，也就是在没有极端恐惧、内疚和焦虑反应的情况下可以吃的食物种类，会急剧萎缩，对吧？所以可能有人开始戒掉某些食物，然后他们戒掉的越来越多，直到最后他们只剩下极少量的所谓“安全食物”，对吧？安全食物基本上就是这样一种食物：这个人可以吃，通常也是有限的分量，吃的时候不会像吃某些其他食物那样产生那么多的焦虑，对吧？有时即使吃所谓的安全食物，也可能仍然会有焦虑，对吧？所以这基本上就是安全食物。在我饮食失调最严重的时候，我的，我该怎么说呢？我拥有的安全食物的种类少得可怜，根本无法维持人类的生命，对吧？有趣的是，当你真的非常非常严格地把食物限制在极少数几种时，接下来很自然的一点就是，你开始，你知道的，去暴食那些……
fall outside of that safe food repertoire, right? So I would have binge per generaxia. So I would restrict myself to a very, very small amount of very specific safe foods. But then as soon as if there was access to other foods, then I'll be very scared of eating them because I felt like I couldn't control myself around them, right? and you said it said it very well, you know that it must be a completely natural response when you are restricting your food intake to be more obsessed with food and have more like food-seeking behavior, right? And this is true. The problem is that a lot of people eating disorders,
不属于这些安全食物清单的食物，对吧？所以我有暴食催吐型厌食症。我会把自己的饮食限制在极少量的、非常特定的安全食物上。但一旦接触到其他食物，我就会非常害怕吃它们，因为我觉得自己在这些食物面前无法控制自己，对吧？你刚才说得很好，你知道的，当你限制食物摄入时，对食物更加执迷并表现出更多寻食行为，这一定是一种完全自然的反应，对吧？事实也确实如此。问题在于，许多患有饮食失调的人，
they think that this response is evidence that they should stay away from food, right? For example, they really restrict their intake and then they become obsessed with food. They binge when, for example, chocolate is available. Then they think, oh, this just shows that I should stay away from these foods. These foods are bad, right? So it comes that, again, self-fulfilling cycle where you avoid more foods, you have the amount of safe foods become smaller and smaller. But then in response, you start focusing more on other foods, right? I remember during my anorexia, I would get so much satisfaction out of just reading food recipes,
他们认为这种反应证明了他们应该远离食物，对吧？例如，他们严格限制摄入，然后变得对食物痴迷。当比如巧克力出现时，他们就会暴食。然后他们会想，哦，这正好说明我应该远离这些食物。这些食物是不好的，对吧？于是这就变成了一个自我实现的循环：你避免更多食物，安全食物的数量变得越来越少。但作为回应，你开始更多地关注其他食物，对吧？我记得在厌食症发作期间，我光是从阅读食物食谱中，
looking at pictures of cake, right? And this is a very normal behavior. But in the moment, you think that, well, what is going on with me, right? And it just really goes to show that I think a lot of people think about eating disorders just as the behaviors, so just as the restriction, but it has so much to do with the mind. And, you know, you have such an amazing scientific knowledge, I think, about this. So where does that fear kind of come from? Like I know in the DSM they talk about it's primarily a fear of gaining weight.
看着蛋糕的照片，就能获得极大的满足感，对吧？这是一种非常正常的行为。但在当时那种情况下，你会觉得，好吧，我到底是怎么了，对吧？这确实表明，我认为很多人仅仅把饮食失调看作是一种行为，仅仅看作是限制饮食，但它其实与心理有着非常大的关系。而且，你知道的，关于这一点，你拥有如此惊人的科学知识。那么，这种恐惧究竟从何而来？我知道在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中，他们提到这主要是一种对体重的恐惧，
It's primarily to do with physical appearance. But I know it also has a lot to do with control, and that fear and anxiety kind of combines with that. So can you explain that a little bit more? So there is disagreements in the field exactly about what is this fear? Why do people with eating disorders act so strange? What is going on there, right? There is no one clear cut answer.
主要与外表有关。但我知道它也很大程度上与控制欲有关，这种恐惧和焦虑交织在一起。所以你能再多解释一下吗？对于这种恐惧究竟是什么，业界其实存在分歧。为什么饮食失调患者的行为会如此诡异？那里到底发生了什么，对吧？没有一个明确清晰的答案。
But what I would say from having had an eating disorder myself and also from working with people with eating disorder and having spoken to so many of them is that the whole fear of fatness, yeah, it may be a role. And we live in a society that kind of reinforced that, right? we live in quite a fat phobic society. Of course, this is reinforced. But I think reducing an eating disorder down to being just about this morbid fear of weight gain
但根据我自己的饮食失调经历，以及与饮食失调患者共事、同他们进行过深入交流的经验，我想说的是，对肥胖的恐惧，是的，它可能起了一定作用。而且我们生活在一个在某种程度上强化这种观念的社会里，对吧？我们生活在一个相当恐惧肥胖的社会里。当然，这得到了强化。但我认为，如果把饮食失调简单归结为仅仅是对体重增加的病态恐惧，
kind of simplifies and trivializes it. For me, I didn't necessarily, like weight gain was not necessarily a massive fear for me. It was just like I had the fear, but that was not like the driving force. The driving force was that this rules and rigidity. You know, when you have a very undernourish brain, your brain becomes very rigid. and very, you know, you lose out on that cognitive flexibility, right? And the way that I tend to see more the fear as is almost like a phobia. It's like a fear response in the brain gone wrong, right?
这就把它给简化和轻视了。对我来说，体重增加不一定是我最大的恐惧。我有这种恐惧，但这并不是驱动力。真正的驱动力是这些规则和刻板性。你知道的，当你的大脑营养不良时，你的大脑会变得非常死板，非常，你知道的，你会丧失那种认知灵活性，对吧？我倾向于把这种恐惧更多地看作是一种恐惧症。它就像是大脑中的恐惧反应出了问题，对吧？
So normally we tend to fear things that are bad for us, right? We tend to fear if a big bear comes running after us, we're going to be like, okay, well, fear response kicks in to protect us, right? And I see that a lot of times, but with eating disorders, is that there is a wrong fear response towards food, right, or towards certain foods. So it essentially is a bit similar to an anxiety disorder, right? I tend to sometimes make people understand just how extreme the fear can be.
通常情况下，我们会害怕对我们有害的事物，对吧？如果有一只大熊朝我们跑来，我们会感到害怕，嗯，恐惧反应会被激活来保护我们，对吧？我很多时候看到的情况是，但在饮食失调中，是对食物或某些特定食物产生了错误的恐惧反应，对吧？所以它本质上有点类似于焦虑症，对吧？我有时会用这个来让人理解这种恐惧究竟可以极端到什么程度。
It can be kind of like, imagine if someone is terrified of spiders, it's like being in a room full of spiders crawling towards you. That is how an eating disorder can sometimes feel like, right? And at the same time, you can feel kind of ridiculous because it's like, why would you be scared of something as fundamental as food, right? But essentially, our brains don't always make much sense. And the starvation also reinforced the fear, right? So it becomes a reinforcing cycle with a fear response gone wrong. That is my interpretation of it.
这有点像是，想象一下如果有人极度害怕蜘蛛，就像身处一个爬满了蜘蛛的房间里。饮食失调有时给人的感觉就是这样，对吧？与此同时，你又会觉得自己很荒谬，因为你会想：为什么会害怕像食物这么基础的东西呢？对吧？但本质上，我们的大脑并不总是那么合乎逻辑。饥饿也会加剧这种恐惧，对吧？所以它变成了一个带有错误恐惧反应的强化循环。这就是我的解读。
But then again, different people in the field will have different takes on it, some more scientific than others, right? And I really love how you pointed out the link between, in this case, anorexia, but really any type of disorder or eating disorder and phobias and anxiety. Because they are so linked that there's been studies that have shown that similar parts of our brains are activated by the behaviors that we use to kind of mitigate anxiety and those that are activated when people control or restrict food. and also that eating disorders are often comorbid. So they occur alongside things like PTSD or things like a phobia, perhaps one that's pretty similar in nature. I really, like there was something you mentioned before that we haven't spoken about yet that I think is really valuable, but also something that not everyone will maybe know about.
不过话又说回来，业内的不同专家对此会有不同的看法，有些比其他的更具科学性，对吧？我真的非常喜欢你指出的这种联系：在这种情况下是厌食症，但实际上是任何类型的失调或饮食失调与恐惧症和焦虑症之间的联系。它们联系是如此紧密，以至于有研究表明，我们大脑中用来缓解焦虑的行为所激活的区域，与人们控制或限制食物时激活的区域是相似的。而且饮食失调通常是共病的。所以它们经常与创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）或某种恐惧症同时出现，也许某种性质相当类似的恐惧症。我真的很——你之前提到过一些我们还没谈过的话题，我认为非常有价值，而且也不是每个人都可能知道的。
And you mentioned outpatient care. So when did you kind of begin to get help? And I know you mentioned you were in out. outpatient care or not in an inpatient facility. What does that really entail? Outpatient essentially just mean, kind of as the word, suggests that you are getting the treatment, but you're not hospitalized, right?
你提到了门诊治疗。那么你是什么时候开始寻求帮助的？我知道你提到过你接受的是门诊治疗，而不是住院治疗。这到底包含什么内容？门诊治疗本质上就意味着，顾名思义，
You're not in a treatment facility 24 hours, right? So inpatient would be someone who's in a psychiatric clinic or in some kind of treatment residential clinic, right? So my treatment was outpatient, which meant that I would go to treatment with, I would see doctor, I would see a dietitian, and also I would see my therapist. In the beginning, it was twice a week or sometimes a bit more, and then gradually reducing the amount of time I was doing that, right?
你正在接受治疗，但你没有住院，对吧？你不是24小时呆在治疗机构里，对吧？所以住院治疗是指某人住在精神病诊所或某种住宅式治疗诊所里，对吧？所以我接受的是门诊治疗，这意味着我会去看医生，看营养师，还会去看心理医生。一开始是每周两次，或者有时稍微多一点，然后逐渐减少治疗的次数，对吧？
And essentially, I was at a point in my anorexia where I was quite poorly, physically was to a point where they were like, if you don't comply with outpatient treatment, then we're putting you in patients, right? And I really didn't want to go in patients, right? I really didn't want to go there. And the reason why I really didn't want to go there was because I knew that if I went inpatient, I would have to eat bread with jam. And I was terrified of eating bread with jam.
基本上，我的厌食症已经发展到身体状况非常糟糕的地步，他们当时说：“如果你不配合门诊治疗，我们就要把你送去住院。”而我真的不想住院，对吧？我真的不想去那儿。我之所以非常不想去，是因为我知道如果我住院了，我就必须吃抹果酱的面包。而我对吃抹果酱的面包感到极度恐惧。
And I was like, if I can avoid eating bread with jam and instead create my own, kind of go work around that and eat safe foods instead, I would do that. And that's just a lot about how sick I was where that for me, that bread with jam was like my biggest fear. And I was like, I'll need to do everything to avoid eating it. It's just so bizarre. Because a lot of times you hear people saying, oh, yeah, I had this turnaround moment where I realized I need to work on my help. But for me, it was more just like fear of going inpatient was what motivated me to engage with outpatient treatment, right?
当时我想，如果我能避免吃抹果酱的面包，转而创造我自己的——绕过这个坎，去吃安全食物，我就会这么做。这很能说明我当时的病情有多严重，抹果酱的面包对我来说竟然是最大的恐惧。我觉得我需要做一切事情来避免吃它。这真是太离奇了。因为很多时候你会听到有人说：“哦，对啊，我当时有个醍醐灌顶的时刻，我意识到我需要为了健康而努力。”但对我来说，与其说是那样，不如说是对住院的恐惧激励我去配合门诊治疗，对吧？
Just to be completely honest. Well, thank you for sharing that because I think that it doesn't really like glamorize it of like you said, like there was this massive turning point. Or I realized that life is worth living. It was like, actually, you know, your recovery, it sounds like there was still fear in that, in that period. still there was still this motivating factor of avoiding or not so much restricting, but that phobia around specific foods. And what was your experience like moving through outpatient? And maybe this is a dumb question, but was there a point where you were like, oh, I'm actually on the end, I'm feeling better. I'm really committed to, you know, being able to eat bread with jam or being able
实话实说就是这样。好吧，谢谢你分享这些，因为我觉得这并没有把事情美化成——就像你说的——出现了一个重大的转折点，或者我突然意识到生命值得活着。情况其实是，你知道的，在你的康复过程中，听起来那个时期依然充满了恐惧。依然存在着一种激励因素，那就是避免或与其说是限制，不如说是对特定食物的那种恐惧症。你经历门诊治疗的过程是怎样的？也许这是一个愚蠢的问题，但有没有那么一个时刻，你会觉得：“哦，我其实已经熬过来了，我感觉好多了。我真的下定决心，你知道的，能够吃抹果酱的面包，或者能够……”
to fully recover from from this disorder? Yeah, so that's a very good question because when I started recovery, I was very much waiting for like a light bulb moment. I think that is often the narrative you hear on eating disorder recovery. Don't give me wrong. That is a lot of people's experience. They may just be like, whoa, I realize life is shorts and I'm doing this, right? But for me, I often say that my light bulb moment was realizing there is no light bulb moment, right? Because I was waiting for that moment to happen and it just kind of didn't, right?
彻底从这种失调中康复？是的，这是一个很好的问题，因为当我开始康复时，我非常渴望出现那种“醍醐灌顶”的时刻。我想这通常是你听到的关于饮食失调康复的故事叙述。别误会我。这确实是很多人的经历。他们可能只是突然觉得：“哇，我意识到生命苦短，我要这么做！”但对我来说，我经常说，我的醍醐灌顶时刻就是意识到——根本没有醍醐灌顶的时刻，对吧？因为我一直在等待那个时刻的到来，而它偏偏就没来，对吧？
the closest thing I came to a moment of whoa I'm doing better whoa I got this was actually when my brain became properly re-nourished right when I had put on some weights when I had been eating more consistently for some time it was almost like my brain went a bit back online if that makes sense right and thankfully I had a psychologist that was very much explaining this to me so the psychologist essentially said that you may not be completely receptive even for therapy and for talking and talking before you are more really nourished and I put on some weight, right? So I remember the point where I started being like, whoa, I actually am, I think I got this. Like, I'm better. It was when I put on some weight, not saying that an eating disorder is magically solved by putting on some weights or eating more, but I'm saying that some of the cognitive symptoms tend to lessen, right? And that is when I was more like, whoa, maybe there is a life outside of this, right? Of course, I did have moments during my early recovery when I was like, yeah, maybe I can do this. You know, I had, but the motivation was very ambivalent. And I think this is one thing to be aware of with eating disorders that people with
我经历过的最接近“哇，我在变好，哇，我能行”的时刻，实际上是我的大脑得到充分的营养补充之后，对吧？当我体重有所增加，当我能够更持续地进食一段时间后，几乎就像我的大脑重新上线了一样，如果这么说能说得通的话，对吧？幸运的是，我的心理医生非常耐心地向我解释了这一点。心理医生基本上是说：在你得到更充分的营养补充并且体重增加之前，你可能甚至无法完全接受心理治疗、倾听和交谈，对吧？所以我记得那个转折点，当时我开始觉得：“哇，我实际上在好转，我想我能行。我变好了。”那是在我体重增加了一些之后——并不是说饮食失调可以通过增加体重或多吃来神奇地解决，而是说一些认知症状往往会减轻，对吧？正是在那个时候，我才更有那种“哇，也许这之外还有生活”的感觉，对吧？当然，在康复初期，我也确实有过一些时刻觉得：“是的，也许我能做到。”你知道的，我有过这种感觉，但这种动力非常矛盾。我想这是需要了解的关于饮食失调的一点，即饮食失调患者的……
eating disorders, recovery can be their biggest fear and biggest goal at the same time. And it's very, very common to be very ambivalent, jump from, oh, I'm, I can't do this to I'm doing this sometimes in the span of like an hour. Like I see this all the time with clients, right? They will be, they will jump from one to the other. Ambivalence is very, very strong, right? So, yeah, that's kind of my experience, but of course, everyone has a different experience when it comes to that. That is so interesting because I love what you just said then about, you can, recovery can be both your biggest fear and your biggest goal, and how when you, just in your experience, when you started putting on weight,
康复过程可能是他们最大的恐惧，同时也是他们最大的目标。而且这种矛盾心理非常非常普遍，会在“哦，我做不到”和“我正在做”之间摇摆，有时甚至在一个小时之内就会发生转变。我经常在客户身上看到这种情况，对吧？他们会从一种状态跳到另一种状态。这种矛盾心理非常非常强烈，对吧？所以，是的，这就是我的经历，当然，每个人在这方面的经历都是不一样的。这太有趣了，因为我非常喜欢你刚才说的话：康复既可以是你的最大恐惧，也可以是你的最大目标；而且就在你的经历中，当你开始增加体重时，
you found that those cognitive functions started to come back, the perhaps elements of the irrationality that is very much a characteristic of this disorder, kind of went away as well. What do you think was the biggest factor in the success of your recovery? Or what do you think really was able to bring you to a place where you can kind of talk about this now? Because I think I was researching this and it was really quite sad but also quite, you know, interesting to see that a lot of people with anorexia don't always recover.
你发现那些认知功能开始恢复，那种作为这种疾病特征的不理性成分可能也随之消失了。你认为你的康复成功最大的因素是什么？或者你认为究竟是什么让你达到了今天可以谈论这件事的地步？因为我在研究时发现，这确实挺让人难过，但也挺——你知道的——有趣：很多患有厌食症的人其实并不能完全康复。
and it is a really hard psychiatric illness to treat. So what do you think was a contributor to your success or your journey? I think there are several factors here. So I think one of them is that my treatment system was, I was quite lucky with having a good psychologist and having access to treatment, right? Because that's another thing with eating disorder treatments, that very often is quite inaccessible, right? I was in Norway at this point, which is my home country.
这是一种非常难治疗的精神疾病。那么，你认为是什么促成了你的成功或你的康复之旅？我认为这里有几个因素。其中之一是我的治疗体系，我很幸运能有一位好的心理医生，并且能够获得治疗的机会，对吧？因为这是饮食失调治疗的另一个问题，它往往很难获得，对吧？当时我在挪威，那是我的祖国，
country and there the treatment is completely free of charge and pretty high quality. So I think that I would kind of think that that the privilege of that definitely was a factor. But of course, even in Norway when people have access to treatment, not everyone recovers, right. So that was one thing, having a good treatment support and also good treatment support that's very much echoed the fact that, yeah, you need to eat, you need to put on weight. You can't just sit here and talk endlessly with us and walk around it. in circles and psychoanalyze, you need to eat as well. And we will sort the other things,
在那里治疗是完全免费的，而且质量相当高。所以我认为这种特权绝对是一个因素。当然，即使在挪威，当人们有机会接受治疗时，也不是所有人都能康复，对吧。所以这是一方面，拥有良好的治疗支持，而且这种治疗支持非常坚定地强调：是的，你需要吃东西，你需要增重。你不能只是坐在这里跟我们无休止地聊天，在原地转圈进行心理分析，你也需要吃东西。我们会解决其他问题，
but you need refeating. I think that for me was very, very crucial. And I also think part of it is my personality type. And I see this in a lot of people with anorexias. They're kind of like, they're a little bit like, we do this or we don't, right? Very much. When I, for example, perfectionism. It's the perfectionism in some ways. When I was, I was given the task of recovery, and I was, for example, I was given a meal plan. I was kind of making a meal plan in collaboration with dietitian, we were working our way around it. But then I was very much like, okay, I'm doing this. I'm not half doing this, right?
但你需要重新进食。我认为这对我来说非常非常关键。我也认为部分原因在于我的性格类型。我在很多厌食症患者身上也看到了这一点。他们有点像是“要么做，要么不做”，对吧？非常坚定。比如当我被赋予康复的任务时，比如我拿到了一份饮食计划——我与营养师合作制定饮食计划，我们围绕它开展工作——但我当时的想法是：“好的，我在做这件事。我绝不半途而废，对吧？”
I think that is my personality that I'm very like, okay, all or nothing, I'm doing this or I don't, right? So, but that is very common trait in some people with anorexia, right? But then, of course, we know also that the rates of full recovery, unfortunately, aren't always so high. We know the relapse rate is very, very high. And that is very unfortunate. I think it boils down to lack of facts to treatment.
我认为这就是我的性格，我是那种“要么全盘接受，要么全盘放弃，我要么做这件事，要么不做”的人，对吧？但这也是某些厌食症患者非常常见的特质，对吧？不过当然，我们也知道完全康复的比率不幸地并非总是那么高。我们知道复发率非常非常高。这是非常不幸的。我认为这归根结底还是在于无法获得治疗、
the nature of an eating disorder and just also sometimes the treatment system isn't always so great. There is a lot of, yeah, there are a lot of misconceptions about eating disorders even within the treatment system that also make it more difficult. Another thing I think is I found a good, I found good support also online and don't get me wrong, online eating disorder recovery communities can be very, very triggering, especially when you, for example, see TikTok, the recovery community. there. I'm not on TikTok, but I took a look there and I was like, whoa, because I wanted to see what my younger clients were looking at because they kept saying TikTok is triggering can be very triggering. But I was very lucky to access, you know, for example, scientific papers and learning about eating disorder and then something kind of clicked in my head. I am very, again, comes down to the personality type, personality thing. I am very like science minded, oh, this is what it is.
饮食失调的本质，以及有时治疗体系本身并不是那么完善。甚至在治疗体系内部，对于饮食失调也存在很多误解，这也使得治疗变得更加困难。我认为另一个因素是，我在网上找到了很好的支持。别误会，线上的饮食失调康复社群可能会非常非常具有触发性，特别是当你看到TikTok上的康复社群时。我不用TikTok，但我去那儿看了一眼，当时就想：“哇……”因为我想看看我较年轻的客户都在看什么，他们一直说TikTok可能会非常具有触发性。但我很幸运能够接触到科学论文等资料，了解了饮食失调，然后我的脑子里仿佛有什么东西“咔哒”一声对上了。我这人——再次回到性格类型上来——非常崇尚科学，心想：哦，原来是这样。
And then I felt like scientifically recovery makes a lot of sense. That's so interesting. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I think that was big factors for me. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, that's really very interesting. And you talked about this very briefly, but like the misconceptions around eating disorders, around anorexia in particular. What are some of those that you come across, perhaps with clients or on social media or just in the general media or rhetoric that we have around this class of conditions?
然后我觉得从科学角度来看，康复是非常合乎逻辑的。太有趣了。对，对，对。所以我觉得这对我是很大的因素。对。哦，这真的非常有趣。你刚才非常简短地谈到了这一点，也就是围绕饮食失调、特别是围绕厌食症的种种误解。你在与客户交往、在社交媒体上、在一般媒体或我们围绕这类病症的言论中，经常遇到哪些误解？
I think the biggest one is. weight, right? So an eating disorder is not necessarily a weight disorder. It is a mental disorder where weight loss can be a side effect in some but not all cases. Actually, it is only in the minority of cases with people that eating disorders are underweight, right? So my case of anorexia and being quite underweight, that is one of the more rare presentations of an eating disorder, right? So I think that is the biggest one. People tend to think that an eating disorder, when someone has an eating disorder, you can see it because they're going to be very the weight. That is not necessarily the case. Some people may gain weight. Some people may lose weight.
我认为最大的一点是体重的误区，对吧？所以，饮食失调不一定是一种体重疾病。它是一种精神疾病，在某些情况下（但并非所有情况）体重减轻可能只是一种副作用。事实上，在饮食失调患者中，体重过轻的只占少数，对吧？所以像我这样患有厌食症且体重相当轻的病例，其实是饮食失调中较为罕见的表现形式，对吧？所以我觉得这是最大的一个误区。人们往往认为，当有人患有饮食失调时，你一眼就能看出来，因为他们体重会非常轻。事实并非总是如此。有些人可能会增重。有些人可能会减轻体重。
Some people may not have that many weight changes. And again, it's not necessarily an indicator of the severity of the illness, right? So that is one big misconception. Another one is that misconception that it only happens to women. That is not true. It can happen to people of any gender. And also people tend to think that it happens only to very young people. It can happen to people of any age. So overall, I think the biggest misconceptions is on who it affects and how it presents, right? And I think it was really interesting when I was looking, I was researching this topic and going back through papers that I had read previously, really deep diving into it. I was like, you know, there is this image when we mention or talk about eating disorders. It's an image of a woman who is very underway in her early 20s or.
有些人可能体重没有太大变化。再说一次，这不一定是病情严重程度的指标，对吧？所以这是一个巨大的误区。另一个误区是认为它只发生在女性身上。这不是真的。它可以发生在任何性别的人身上。人们还往往认为它只发生在极年轻的人身上。它可以发生在任何年龄的人身上。总的来说，我认为最大的误区在于它影响了谁以及它是如何表现的，对吧？我觉得很有意思的是，当我研究这个主题、重温我以前读过的论文、深入探讨它时，我想：你知道，当我们提及或谈论饮食失调时，脑海中会出现一个固定的形象——一个二十出头或青春期晚期、体重极轻的女性。
late teens. And it doesn't account for the fact that binge eating disorder exists or bulimia or that there aren't people who are what we would typically say are an unhealthy weight or underweight. Or there are men or people of many genders who experience this. And I think that's so, I think that's something that we have to kind of retrain the narrative and change the narrative around because it doesn't make treatment accessible. It doesn't do much for. the stigma and discrimination. So I think that's an amazing point that you brought up. I do want to say, so you do a lot of counselling. I think that's amazing, amazing work. What would be one huge or maybe less huge, just a significant piece of advice that you might give to someone who's listening
而这并没有考虑到暴食症或贪食症的存在，也没有考虑到有些人并不符合我们通常所说的“不健康体重”或“体重过轻”的标准。或者还有男性或各种性别的人也在经历这种状况。我认为这是我们必须重新构建和改变叙事方向的事情，因为现有的叙事让治疗变得难以获取，也无助于消除污名化和歧视。所以我觉得你提出这一点真的太棒了。我想说的是，你做了大量的咨询工作。我觉得这是一项了不起的、不可思议的工作。对于正在收听这个节目、心想“好吧，我想康复，我想从这之中治愈”的人，你会给他们一条什么样重大（或者不那么重大、但很有意义）的建议？你会对他们说些什么？你会给出什么建议？
to this right now who's like, okay, well, I want to recover. I want to heal from this. What would you say to them? What advice would you give to them? I think my best advice would be do that work and don't postpone it and think that there's going to be a magical future moment when you're ready to recover because that's not how an eating disorder work, right? Seek the help now. And also when it comes to treatment, if you seek out help and you find that that particular treatment is not really working for you, right, then it's okay to seek another form of treatment, right? For example, I see some people may start, you know, psycho-analysing their entire childhood and feel like that doesn't really help and they realize they need a bit more of practical. Maybe they need to go for an
我想我最好的建议就是：去做这项工作，不要拖延，也不要总想着未来会有那么一个神奇的时刻，当你准备好时再去康复，因为饮食失调可不是那样运作的，对吧？现在就去寻求帮助。而且在治疗方面，如果你寻求了帮助，却发现这种特定的治疗方法对你并不真正管用，那么去寻找另一种形式的治疗是完全可以的，对吧？例如，我看到有些人可能开始对自己的整个童年进行精神分析，却觉得这并没有什么实质帮助，他们意识到自己需要更务实的方法。也许他们需要去住院治疗，或者也许他们需要更专注于重新进食。找到适合你的方法。找一个让你觉得站在你这边的治疗团队，
inpatient stay or maybe they need to be a bit more focused on refitting. You know, find out something that works for you. Find a treatment team that you feel is on your side, but also find a treatment team that is against the eating disorder. If your treatment team seems to be just fearing the same thing the eating disorder is fearing, they're probably no good, right? I hear this a lot of people have, their treatment team would be like, okay, yeah, don't put on too much weight. Oh, don't get too. You know, be careful. Don't eat too much, right? I'm not joking. This is unfortunately, what? I know it's ridiculous, but unfortunately, it is a common experience, right? So find a team that's on your side and don't postpone and think that you're magically going to be ready in the future
但也要找一个敢于对抗饮食失调的治疗团队。如果你的治疗团队似乎在和饮食失调恐惧着同样的事，那他们可能就不合格，对吧？我经常听到有人说，他们的治疗团队会这样：“哦，对啊，别增重太多。哦，别变得太……你知道的，小心点，别吃太多。”我没开玩笑。不幸的是，这就是——我知道这很荒谬，但不幸的是，这是一种很常见的经历，对吧？所以，找一个站在你这边的团队，不要拖延，也不要幻想着未来某天你会奇迹般地准备好，
because that's not how an eating disorder work. Trust me, I work with people who've thought that and they've had eating disorders for several decades, right? But I also want to say that if you are someone who've had an eating disorder for a long time or a short time, recovery is possible. There's another thing I see people who've had an eating disorder for a long time. They may think that their case is impossible to recover from, but that is not necessarily the case. Recovery is still possible, so please, please don't lose hope on that sense.
因为饮食失调的运作方式根本不是这样的。相信我，我接触过那些曾这么想过的人，他们的饮食失调甚至持续了数十年，对吧？但我也想说，无论你经历饮食失调的时间是很长还是很短，康复都是可能的。这是我看到的另一件事：那些饮食失调很久的人可能会认为他们的病例是不可能康复的，但事实并非一定如此。康复依然是可能的，所以请千万、千万不要在这方面失去希望。
That is such a positive and beautiful message to end on. Thank you so much. I just think that this was such an amazing conversation to have and I'm so, so grateful that you came on, that you were able to be so vulnerable and insightful. So thank you so much for your time. Thank you for having me. And also, I'm going to give a plug to your amazing podcast, Recovery Talk. You know, I feel like I talk about different topics every week.
这是一个如此积极且美好的信息，用来作为结尾再合适不过了。非常感谢你。我只是觉得这是一场无与伦比的对话，我非常、非常感激你能来到这里，表现得如此坦诚且富有洞察力。所以非常感谢你抽出时间。谢谢邀请我。顺便我也要为你的精彩播客《Recovery Talk》宣传一下。你知道的，我觉得我每周都在谈论不同的话题。
So if this topic was one that you're like, I want to know more, there is so much psychology behind this, and you talk about it so much on your show in such a beautiful and articulate way. So I will leave links in the bio, in the episode description. And of course, what's your Instagram handle? Maybe people can give you a follow to see your amazing content. Yeah, so my Instagram is Amalia Lee. And I also have a Instagram more oriented towards eating disorder recovery, which is let's recover.com.com.
所以如果这个话题正是你想要了解更多的，这里面包含着如此多的心理学知识，而且你在节目中以一种如此优美且清晰的方式谈论它。所以我会把链接放在简介和单集介绍里。当然，你的Instagram账号是什么？也许大家可以去关注你，看你精彩的内容。好的，我的Instagram是Amalia Lee。我还有一个专门针对饮食失调康复的Instagram账号，叫做let's recover.com。
Well, thank you so much for coming on. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast. Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, it really helps the show to grow and reach new people. I really hope that this episode taught you something, that you learnt something, that you can bring it into your own life or the lives of people around you. That's always the aim. And like I said at the beginning of this episode, we do now have merch available. So if you want to support the podcast, you want to allow us to keep doing what you're doing, please have a browse. have a bye, whatever you would like to do, and we will be back next week for another episode.
非常感谢您的光临。如果您喜欢这期节目，请随手在 Apple Podcasts 或 Spotify 等任何您收听的平台上留下五星好评，这真的对节目的成长和触达新听众很有帮助。我真心希望这期节目能教给您一些东西，让您有所收获，并能将其带入您自己的生活或身边人的生活中。这始终是我们的目标。正如我在节目开头所说的那样，我们的周边商品现在已经开售了。如果您想支持本节目，想让我们继续做现在做的事，请随意浏览或购买，您想怎么做都行。我们下周将推出另一期节目。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct?
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不安全而无法进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套坚固的铠甲？它向世界释放出信号：你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听《Learn the Hardway》。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦斯女士，这份特定的检测报告是你篡改了两次，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
我只篡改了一次检测报告。这需要动用一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格蕾丝，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·兰基尼。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
这里是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这是在旁边有自动扶梯的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健康和建立抗逆力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上的 T-W-A-Percent。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hand. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能就这样逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听《The Girlfriends》。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档 iHeart 播客。纯人工保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。